welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and avengers zen game and the rules
of time travel in the marvel cinematic
universe
just got overturned by of all things a
book what are those actually i'm really
glad we got shuri here because it's the
new book from marvel and epic ink called
the wakanda files
presented as a compilation of shuri's
research on
all the tech in the mcu from weapons to
ai to the quantum realm with
hidden messages revealed by a uv light
from a kimoyo bead
i still don't know what these books are
but i assume they're all like this and
they sound great just to be careful
pointing that beat anywhere in your room
gross one of these passages sheds some
uv light on one lingerie mystery from
avengers end game that has come back up
recently
how much iron man tony stark knew
exactly
going into the time heist and his final
battle with thanos he obviously knew
more than he let on right
he pre-recorded a goodbye message
suggesting he remembered that
one future in which they won would
require his
self-sacrifice which is why he knew from
strange's quivering finger alone what to
do
and we've explored how he secretly
designed his new stark gauntlet
specifically to be compatible with his
own nanotech so that he'd be able to
discreetly absorb the stones off
thanos's hand onto his
and yeah i've also gone deeper into that
to suggest the gauntlet never would have
worked had thanos actually snapped it
with all the stones in there that it was
secretly a one-time fuse that hulk
already ignited when he snapped and
the whole thing was a trick to blur
thanos into a false sense of confidence
anyway
the new detail that this marvel book
exposed is an
encrypted message from tony stark to
bruce banner written around the time
tony was
engineering that wrist gps quantum
navigator according to sci-fi
wire tony mentions the david deutsch
model of quantum mechanics and he says
quote
altering events from the past could
never affect the continuous loop
though it could create tangential split
timelines let's not worry about that for
the time being right
one reality at a time for all our sanity
new stuff the deutsche proposition
actually came up earlier in the film
tony after everything you've seen is
anything really quantum fluctuation
messes with the plank scale which then
triggers the deutsche proposition can we
agree on that
tony was referring to the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics an
assumption that einstein's theory of
space-time is false
allows for the theoretical possibility
that multiple realities could coexist
simultaneously and this message from
stark to banner explains how banner was
such a know-it-all to scott rhodey
clinton nebula think about it
if you travel to the past that past
becomes your future
and your former present becomes the past
which can't now be changed by your new
future exactly
but the most interesting implication is
the question it brings up over how much
stark knew going into this
because right before they confront
thanos tony tells cap
if you mess with time it tends to mess
back you'll see
now in the moment we read this as tony
just warning cap that thanos himself is
the kind of
embodiment of fate inevitably returning
to haunt
anyone who tries to subvert it by
messing with the laws of nature but
in the many months since first hearing
it many of us have reinterpreted this
line
as a possible hint at the even greater
unseen
chaos the avengers have unleashed upon
the multiverse by meddling with these
timelines
one threat we recently learned about is
kang the conqueror
marvel's time lord villain confirmed to
be played by jonathan majors in ant-man
3.
did tony stark know that kang was coming
well there was another visual clue and
end game that to this day has
never been explained the quantum tunnel
device
when evil nebula hijacks it to bring
2014 thanos into the present features
may 2012 that was the time of the battle
of new york that they went to in the
time heist but also
two other completely random years
january
2988 bc and november 2009
80. i have explained how 2988 bc was the
earliest known historical date of an
infinity stone the reality stone with
the ether appearing in thor's ancestor
boar's battle with the dark elves shown
in the prologue of thor the dark world
set
in the year 2988 and 2009 would have
been sometime between iron man 1 and
iron man 2 when nick fury would have
been experimenting with the tesseract
under project pegasus now these could
just have been alternate time
destinations being considered by the
avengers as they were plotting out the
time heist
but now that we know tony was aware of
the dangers of tangential split
timelines
i think that reframes how we should
interpret this clue
but before i continue thank you to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
sweet every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and it has zero calories
yet it tastes real great
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from one of those great flavors
is
bangster berry a berry that i presume
due to mandatory sentencing laws
probably went to jail for a long time
because being a bankster doesn't pay
but it does make a delicious energy
drink check out bang on instagram you
can get
25 off your order at bang energy.com
when you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
they got a sweet tea flavor they got a
keto
coffee flavor you can also get clothing
or fitness supplements all kinds of
stuff to be your best bang so
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get twenty five
percent off at bang energy.com using the
code
newrockstars25 so of course the timeline
of avengers in game is real tricky
there's the five year time jump scott
lang experiences time dilation
the ancient one changes the movie's
timeline logic halfway through but most
importantly
each of their separate time missions
conclude with all of them returning to
the same exact moment in the present as
marty mcfly observes when you have a
time machine
you can return to whenever you want oh
by the way last year i analyzed the
dueling depictions of time travel and
end game and
back to the future and we're gonna
release it publicly on the channel in a
few days don't listen to scott lang back
to the future is not a bunch of [ __ ]
but one time jump i think many of us
missed is the one that occurred right
after the obvious timeline meddling was
supposedly finished
after the five surviving og avengers
grieve over natasha on the dock
the next shot we see of them is in
tony's lab when they're fitting the
stones into stark's new gauntlet
but the editing hides the fact that some
time must have passed here
many of them are now suited up in
different clothes you know long it must
have taken big banner to change a top
he can't afford to just rip them all off
we did rank bruce banner as the most
likely to be on welfare i think this
little time gap explains how those
extra numbers could have ended up on
that quantum tunnel console
just before nebula snuck over to it and
this new reveal from the book
explains stark's motive see remember cap
grabbed
four extra pym particle vials from hank
pym's lab in 1970.
stark and cap only needed one each to
get back to the present that leaves
two extra pin particles lying around in
the present day
giving stark the opportunity the motive
and the time
to conduct two additional jumps to the
past
and before you say cap needed those
extra piles for the return trip
he clearly needed more than two there
were six stones separated from at least
four different points in space time and
presumably the avengers reloaded on them
from like hank pym
who was at the funeral or the ones
thanos apparently reverse engineered
according to the directors so what was
stark's secret time mission well this
book confirms that stark
knew about alternate realities that he
warned bruce banner not to worry about
yet and when he tells cap that time will
mess back
he says you'll see through his solitary
experimentation stark
must have known that some dark force is
out there in the time stream
playing it all like a goddamn harp yeah
i think tony stark
knew about kang the conqueror and the
way kang has
already controlled the time stream to
enable his future dominion
and his kingdom in chronopolis which i
think that city in the quantum realm is
more or less confirmed to be at this
point
stark new kang would create one of many
branch realities by first snatching the
reality stone back from the year 2988 bc
so stark went back to stop him and clip
off that branch but stark also knew that
kang would do the same with the space
stone in 2009 so he thwarted kang again
and clipped off that branch so that's
two jumps two files and by 2009 hank pym
would be over there on the west coast so
for tony it would just be a matter of
zipping on over to hank pym's lab
stealing another particle and then
returning to the present
just in time to help banner zip up into
his activewear look folks stark went
through
something that we didn't see there was
an additional grimness in his eyes
when he said those words to cap just
moments after this
you'll see and i think it is because
tony stark knew there were
many other alternate realities
controlled by one dark force kang the
conqueror a time stream that tony stark
tried to clip off but was unable to
completely damn that stream
and he knows here that it's going to be
on the surviving avengers of the future
to face
a future that tony stark won't be a part
of subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
adavos follow me rockstars thanks for
indulging me as i pitched how tony stark
went back in time to
bangkang let's add a kang bang
[Music]
you